status anxiety is one of the most
pernicious widespread of all diseases it
can ruin large sections of our lives and
a good approach to life means having a
philosophy that we can deal with it and
recognize the problem for what it is
look as soon as you finish college what
starts to matter is what you do in life
the first question becomes what do you
do and according to how you answer that
question people are either incredibly
pleased to see you or make a run for it
in other words how clever and nice and
friendly and you know sympathetic you
are ceases to matter in most social
occasions we live in a world surrounded
by snobs what is a snob a snob is
someone who takes a small part of you
and uses that to judge the whole of you
and I'm dominant snobbery nowadays is
job snobbery so what is on your business
card determines your identity this is a
deeply frightening vision partly it's
frightening because most of us are
unable to bring our true richness of
character and personality in line with
our business card we are being judged we
feel in a humiliating way we feel
there's so much in us that is not God an
expression in capitalism you know
capitalism is a machine that recognizes
outward financial external achievement
and most of us carry all kinds of
richness which we unable to translate
into that language there are very few of
us whose full complexity of character
has been brought out as it were on their
business card most of us what is special
about us requires it requires love and
by love I mean imagination it requires
someone to say even though that person
looks a bit it could be anything
boring uninteresting unimportant a dull
actually that's because I'm only looking
at them in the first 30 seconds they
need more time the cruelty of the modern
world the cruelty of New York City for
example so this is a city where people
give you 30 seconds and not much longer
if you're not careful and that's very
challenging cuts people up inside it
literally drives you crazy
you